Let's get into audience questions for the
week, starting with, hey, David, what do you
believe is the future of the progressive movement
in the Democratic Party or is the future of
American progressivism outside of the Democratic
Party?
So there's a philosophical debate here.
There's an ideological debate to be had about
will the Democratic Party allow itself to
become a truly progressive party or will it
not allow that meaning that if progressives
want a real foothold in the United States,
they will have to work outside the Democratic
Party as third party candidates or whatever
else the case may be?
Beautiful conversation.
I love it.
Completely irrelevant.
If if campaign finance is not reformed and
arguably if we don't actually change our system
of elections away from a first past, the post
winner take all system.
I think that if you look at the Tea Party
movement of 2010, if the Tea Party movement
had decided to work exclusively outside of
the Republican Party instead of just having
Tea Partiers run as Republicans, had the Tea
Party succeeded at taking seats, it actually
would have weakened the Republican Party.
And by its very but by by the inverse, it
would have strengthened the Democratic Party.
Why is that?
If the Tea Party candidates were not running
as Republicans, they would have been running
against Republicans.
They would have disproportionately taken votes
from Republicans.
They would have played spoilers for Republicans,
and they likely wouldn't have won as many
seats either.
Right.
So you would have had some cases where Republican
seats would have been lost to Tea Party seats
as third parties, and that would have weakened
the Republican Party.
You also would have had seats that a Tea Partier
running inside the Republican Party could
have won, but would not have because Republican
money would have poured into the Republican
candidate and not the Tea Party candidate.
So because campaign finance is what it is
and because we have a voting system, that
is what we have.
The Tea Party won a bunch of seats in 2010
in the midterms because they ran as Republicans
at the local level, some didn't, but nationally
they ran as Republicans.
Eventually, the Tea Party became integrated
into the Republican Party and the Republican
Party overall was moved towards the Tea Party.
This was a massive win for the Tea Party.
You don't really hear much about the Tea Party
anymore.
It's just part of the Republican Party at
this point in time.
That's an example of a success at changing
the party.
Now, there's an argument to be made that Democrats
are not Republicans, that the Democratic Party
would not ever be so influenced by a progressive
wing like the Tea Party was able to influence
the Republican Party because they're just
fundamentally different parties.
I completely disagree with this.
And the evidence is look at how the Democratic
Party has already moved in the last five years
since Bernie Sanders in 2015 started more
prominently talking about Medicare for all
free college to a lesser extent, then more
in 2020, minimum wage increase.
A lot of the stuff that was made prominent
by progressives back in 2015, 2016, 2017 is
now relatively mainstream in the Democratic
Party.
Now, there is no question that because the
Democratic Party, as much as the Republican
Party, are very corporate influenced establishment
parties, you still see, you know, a majority
of Democratic senators don't support something
like Medicare for all right now.
But I think the evidence is clear that the
progressive wing progressives have already
influenced the Democratic Party.
So my position is, if we don't change campaign
finance, move to public funding of elections,
limit the duration of a campaign, limit how
much money can be spent.
Eliminate PACs, all that different stuff.
I don't believe progressives have a serious
chance outside of the Democratic Party.
It pains me to say it.
There's actually also a backfire risk if progressives
outside of the Democratic Party did a good
job of taking some seats away from Democrats
running independent third party in the short
and even medium term, it probably helps Republicans
by strengthening them in comparison to the
Democratic Party, the progressive wing, these
progressive independents would be too small
to really get very much done in the long term.
It's a question mark and we don't know.
So right now, if progressives were to break
off and form their own party, it could very
much damage the Democratic Party.
If you're an acceleration ist right.
If you prefer Trump over Biden, if it can't
be Bernie, then maybe you like that.
Maybe you want to see the Democratic Party
destroyed.
In order to at some point in the future build
it back up, that's a philosophical discussion.
In practice, I don't see any way that if we
if we don't reform public campaign finance
and if we don't reform how our election systems
work.
I don't see any way that progressive succeed
at the national level.
Local is different by working outside the
Democratic Party.
Go, go bigger than the Democratic Party, of
course.
But in terms of electoral politics, you've
got to fix campaign finance and how we do
elections first.
If you want progressives to have a shot outside
the Democratic Party at really making an influence.
Hey, David.
Does the hashtag Never Biden movement help
or hurt progressives?
So there are elements to this question that
are similar to the elements of whether the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party should
simply separate from the Democratic Party
altogether.
First and foremost, the never Biden people
who insist Biden can't win.
These are the exact same folks who believed
it, even when it was very clear Bernie had
no shot to the nomination that Bernie was
going to be the nominee.
So in terms of their ability to do political
prognostication, I would not put too much
weight behind the opinions of the hashtag.
Never Biden movement.
But I think that they bring an important question
to the table, which is over the long term.
Over the long term.
Does the progressive movement benefit or not
from Joe Biden winning in 2020?
Now, I did a segment about this a couple of
months ago.
I am no stranger to this idea.
If you sort of take a game theory perspective,
you can argue that the best thing for progressives
is for Biden to be the nominee, but to lose
to Trump.
Why could that be the best thing for progressives
over the long term?
This is theoretical.
Well, Biden's the nominee and loses.
It gives progressives the strongest position
to say, we told you, we told you an establishment
Democrat can't win.
We need an actual progressive as the nominee.
And it would potentially position a real progressive
for 2024 to potentially become the next president
of the United States.
After Donald Trump's second term.
Right.
That's the game theory question now.
In practical terms, how much damage is done
for decades if Donald Trump gets to pick one
or two more Supreme Court justices during
his second term?
But that's not trivial.
How much damage is done to the environment
if we get four years of Trump versus four
years of Biden, who supports the Green New
Deal as a framework?
If not fully, admittedly, how much does our
economy suffer if we get four more years of
Donald Trump's tax plan as opposed to Joe
Biden's, which is better on marginal tax rates,
which is better on the taxing of capital gains?
I could go on.
So I believe that if you want to ignore the
damage and destruction that Donald Trump will
do in a second term, in a game theory, hypothetical
perspective, there is a very good case to
be made that in the long run, maybe the progressive
movement is more jumpstarted by Biden losing
in November than winning.
In practical terms, as a person who gets one
vote and has the decision to make, do I take
an action that reinstall as Trump or do I
take an action that removes him?
I have to vote for Joe Biden.
That's my moral compass.
I can't take an action that would make it
more likely Trump gets four more years and
this gets us to incrementalism versus acceleration
ism.
When I look at history and I've done this
before, I won't I won't bore people by doing
it again.
When people say, hey, let's bloods, burn it
down to build it back up.
I don't see instances in the last hundred
and fifty years of American history where
that was actually what worked.
Other than through cataclysm and massive death,
when we look at the Progressive Era, the New
Deal era and the civil rights era.
Yes, there were protests.
Yes, there was some violence.
Yes.
And I'm not minimizing it by saying some.
I don't mean what I mean is in the grand scheme
of things.
Those were advances that happened because
of peaceful protests, because of who was on
the Supreme Court at the time and was able
to uphold some of those changes.
So the theoretical question of the long term
progressive movement's success, if Biden loses
versus if he wins, let's do it.
When it comes to November, I can't take an
action that helps Donald Trump.
OK, last question today.